one of my
concerns when it comes to the kyle
rittenhouse trial
has been that whatever the legal outcome
the right-wing media is going to make
this kid a hero or a martyr and what i
mean by that is
if he's acquitted
he will be made a hero and it will be
a bellwether example
of how you can choose to go out and be
an armed vigilante
even if you've got the gun illegally
uh you can create a situation in which
you end up fearing for your life not
denying maybe he did right you create a
situation
and you go free
and he is going to if he is acquitted be
held up as a hero by the right when in
reality this is a failure of parenting
it's a failure of culture it's a failure
of so many different things
if he's found guilty on any of the
counts he does any jail time whatever he
will be then seen as a martyr
and the problem here is thinking that he
did something good he shouldn't have
been there he was carrying the gun
illegally after killing one person he
didn't even try to leave he ended up
killing a second person and shooting a
third person
so of course in the lionization of kyle
rittenhouse right in the middle of the
trial sean hannity decides to interview
the mom wendy rittenhouse she agrees to
go on fox news and it's as bad as you
can imagine let's just start somewhere
the topic of white supremacy comes up
and sean hannity says i've seen no
evidence at all that would suggest he's
even maybe a white supremacist let's
take a look at that when the then
candidate now president of the united
states
and other elected officials
that don't know anything about your son
refer to him as a white supremacist
i have yet to see any evidence
whatsoever
that he is such a person now
i don't know if kyle rittenhouse is a
white supremacist i've not mentioned it
during the trial and i just don't know
but kyle rittenhouse was photographed at
a bar
uh holding up that upside down okay
symbol now often associated with white
supremacy so it might not be definitive
might not be definitive evidence but
hannity's saying there's no evidence
there's a very weak comment
part of the this kid's a victim
he's a great kid all of his beliefs are
great
and he's a hero for what he did with the
guns
kyle written rittenhouse's mom by the
way is a big fan of the judge now it's
not a big surprise for those saying the
judge has just called balls and strikes
and isn't helping one side or the other
if the mom felt
the judge was not useful to them she
would not be saying the judge is great
okay so big surprise she likes the judge
take a look
the judge is very fair
um people that i talked to that lived in
kenosha
all their lives
they told me that judge schroeder is a
very fair drudge
and he doesn't allow no nonsense
in his courtroom
not a surprise not a surprise the
judge's decisions have been to the
extent that he's a factor at the trial
his decisions have been mostly good for
the defense
then the topic came up
of when
kyle rittenhouse was being uh directly
examined by his own defense attorneys he
started crying the images in the video
have gone viral i've not commented on
was it real or not were the tears real
was it stage whatever i i have no idea
she says uh well he was heart she was
heartbroken by that
that's your son
how did that make you feel
it just
i just broke down with with kyle crying
like that
it made me feel
heartbroken
sad
and i wanted to just go up there and
just hug him and tell him it would be
okay
this is part of
turning the kid into a hero
via
turning the kid into a victim that's
part of it
um here's the real cherry on top
would kyle do it all over again in the
same way
and his mom says
he probably would
have you and your son discussed
whether or not if he had to do it over
again he would go into a situation like
that
with kyle
i know him and he probably would do it
again because that's the type of person
he is
not even and i would encourage him not
to go
even if it's self-defense
this is a tragedy to be avoided at all
cost
two people are dead it has ruined our
lives look at what we are now embroiled
in i would tell him not to go kyle
yeah he'd probably do it again they've
learned nothing
it's not like he went and saved 10
people so it was worth it it's not like
he went and through his providing
medical
as he was supposedly there to do people
survived who wouldn't have
it's he he just went and people died and
now he's in the middle of a trial and he
would do it all again sadly
i think she's right that's the saddest
thing and you know the the right loves
to talk about the importance of
parenting this is a total parenting
failure and the interview is proof of
that now one last thing i want to say
about the mom and i want to say it
carefully
there are people who have written to me
and they said david
the mom isn't cognitively there
if you listen to their interviews and
the way she talks and you see her
presence in in the courtroom
some she's disabled cognitively and
everybody should give her a break i
don't know where people are getting that
i don't i've i researched it because
eight or ten people wrote to me about
that
is it her appearance that you're basing
that on i found nothing about the mom
being cognitively limited in any way i
don't know if the com comments are
classist in some way i have no idea what
her level of education is i believe
she's a nurse so to some degree she's
educated uh i don't know anything about
that and for me it's not playing a role
in analyzing the things that she's
saying so there's the interview with the
mom not particularly surprising as far
as the content and we'll have some of
these clips on our instagram at david
pakman show where you you can also
comment and let me know what you think
of that interview
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video